productions
so that we know who's who's talking so
i'll start with me
uh hopefully the majority of you know me
i'm jacqueline i'm strategic theme lead
for prosperity
um and in that job role and
sort of unusual job title means i pick
up the
things of economic development business
engagement
a little bit on tourism and a few other
a few other strands that fall under the
same thing
and my role um is to try and ensure that
the district is as prosperous as
possible so that means about
attracting new businesses to the area
trying to support those that we already
have
and also trying to capitalize on the uh
sort of
special things that the district has in
terms of its uh
visitor economy are
very much valued uh high streets and
independent businesses
um and this project has has been part of
that
this keep it local initiative and also
the work that we're doing with
the north essex economic board which
i'll come on to when we when we reach
click it local the other main strand of
the way we work is through our strategic
partnership with sense of place
uh and that gives me the opportunity to
hand over to
uh charlie who perhaps you could
introduce your chart yourself charlie
um and just touch on a little bit of uh
how we've worked over the last
well it's been a few years but perhaps
focus on most recent history
in terms of sense of place and its role
with with the council
but you'll have to turn yourself off
mute charlie
great thanks check i got scared when you
started taping me so i
immediately went on mute um yes i i
think a lot of it and many of you know
me
chairman of sense of place charlie
fillingham um
sense of place is a concept more than
anything it really is about the fact
that
um we all know that if in certain
initiatives
if businesses get together with council
and other stakeholders
especially those who might have purse
strings it is great
how the coming and the bringing together
of initiatives
kind of end up with a much bigger and
greater result um
and um councils certainly have embraced
the idea as they had been cut back more
and more
in in terms of funds um so it's a
concept that has used
quite many councils now throughout the
country um
we have worked on a number of
initiatives um
hopefully encouraging and bringing
people together um
and um i mean certainly
looking at aspects such as skills as
apprenticeships whereby we know that
the only way to run schemes like that is
about bringing people together
the idea of click it local or keep it
local is certainly something that's very
dear certainly to our hearts
whereby we know that if we can come up
with a
initiative a branding an idea that
really covers the whole of the
independent local businesses it will
much more likely to find funding and
support
um not just from customers but but
actually from funders right throughout
the whole district so
keep sense of place is all about that
it's all about trying to encourage to
bring people together
um and coming up with the some of the
parts uh which is much greater
i think that really covers me
yeah thank you charlie um
so this meeting to some extent is uh the
first of uh
um joint meetings between the malden
business board
and the very newly formed uh burnham
business board and i'm pleased to see
we've got
some amount of crossover between us we
know that
working with our with our local
businesses
is going to be vital to us and i think
it's fair to say um unless you'd like to
take over at this point alison as chair
of the malden business
board i think we're very proud of the
work that's been done um
with the molden group so far and its
uh membership has been as positive as it
can be during a pandemic
and there's achieved a number of things
that simply would not have been anywhere
near possible
if it were just the council trying to do
things off our own back
i wouldn't want to take away from
businesses they probably could have done
it on their own but i hope we were
helpful
so it's showing the strength of that
partnership approach
and i'm really hoping that we can uh try
and facilitate the same within burnham
uh some really active membership and
thank you for uh the i think four people
i had over the weekend who
expressed their interest in the burnham
business board so that's
exciting to know that it's a potentially
a forum that people will find
valuable but certainly interesting at
this stage
just to give an outline of how uh this
uh
these are structured because i know
sometimes it can be a little confusing
so sense of place
um as well as being its concept um is a
a board in its own right and they're the
district level uh group of business
leaders
that we talk to and consult with and try
and
initiate projects through they have been
the um
steering board essentially to the
creation of um
keep it local and they've worked with us
on a number of things to try and bring
forward
initiatives for the district
underneath that we have a a need for
more localized
focused efforts and that's where the
mold and business board
has focused around the town of malden
and the burnham business board
will focus around burnham but without
drawing strong lines so we know that
areas um such as the rest of the dengue
will of course link in economically with
the function of
how well the town prospers so
just as a nod there is still gaps
in in both boards of how we want to
engage with businesses
in mold and of course things like
ensuring our links in with the
causeway of wick hill of other
employment sites
and in burnham we've only just got
started and we've already
identified things around their
industrial parks
their sailing communities and other
areas that
lend to the economic strengths of the
area so we envisage a
molden district business network
underneath sense of place
and these two boards that we've uh
supported to come about already have
been the starting point for that
next one on our list is probably
something like a rural group
if anyone's uh got particular rural
interests
but that's the next one on my my list
so i hope that's a sensible introduction
to the
structure the both groups um
have their own terms of reference their
own um
we're certainly a chairman for molden at
the moment where we've put a
request out for someone to put their
hand up for chairman of burnham
of the business board that is of course
um
and uh we'll be working with them to to
stabilize them as we have the
molden group both will be working
towards bringing forward an action plan
some of those actions are identified for
molden and we've got
ideas that have already been raised
through the burnham group of what
the businesses there would like to see
happen
and we feel that's a really strong way
forward certainly that's been really
productive uh i hope charlie would agree
and
how we've managed to get things
progressed uh
through the sense of place board that
without being insulting to it was
previously a good meet up and a good
chat to think about the problems but
without a delivery mechanism to make
make those solutions come forward and
that gives me a good opportunity to just
introduce ashley um in the top corner of
my screen but uh
could be anywhere for yours ashley is
our sense of place coordinator
um grant funded so no cost to the
taxpayer which is exciting
or at least the modern taxpayers um
but actually supports uh charlie um
and and i uh in enabling
the sense of place network and the both
the malden
and the burnham business board and
there's a good point of contact
um for anyone for the businesses she
also maintains
uh our presence in terms of linkedin and
the business group that we use
on there to try and share the best
information out there and i think
everyone knows that over the last year
the sheer volume of information uh
that's being shared and what digging
through that to find what's important to
you and your business
is quite a hard task and
we tried to do our best to share that
information
i'll pause just uh let's give myself a
break
do we have any questions on uh sense of
place the
modern district business network and the
structure we're trying to
try to enable and bring forward
i think most people are fairly well up
to speed certainly
members of the moulton board have
probably heard me
iterate some version of that several
times
okay good
well the first project we want to talk
about um
and give some time to discuss because
there are
uh certain bits of it that are um
underway and
we're gonna be kicking off today and
there are other bits that um
we've still got some uh shaping to do
so keep it local is an initiative uh
spurred by
our partnership with sense of place and
through membership of the mold and
business board we've been able to shape
that into
uh we what we think is a really
productive and exciting project
we were really fortunate to secure grant
funding uh for the project
uh in the order of about eighteen
thousand pounds which isn't huge
but it does give us uh ability to uh get
a few things done
and to try and support local and focused
on
independent uh business and this is
really focused around our high streets
and ensuring they are sustainable for
the future
that they adapt as necessary to the
changing environment but we
continue to have that really excellent
base of independent retail
of independent restaurants and galleries
and public services and personal
services and all those things that
really make our
high streets a a hub of the community
and a really valued
part of our overall economy
keep it local uh had a number of strands
as it was
going through and being scoped and
shaped but the bits that have been
um have been funded uh we're really
pleased about so the first one i want to
talk about is the
training which training i want to use in
a fairly loose uh way i think i think of
it perhaps more around sort of
consultancy or mentoring for businesses
and we've got there's two strands to
that
as identified by the survey we did
earlier last year
which came out on top as the two main
things that the businesses need at this
time
and that's around uh web and online
presence
and also around digital marketing
as to obviously fairly fairly new
i mean they have been around for quite a
while but in terms of our high streets
they
are they are the young ones um
so they were both identified by the
businesses that we surveyed last year as
strands that they'd want to be
supported in and through securing
modest amounts of money we've been able
to commission
two experts in those fields and their
time
will be available uh for people for
businesses locally
um we've set up a an application form
so i can talk you through that process
in a moment but if i may i'd like to
introduce
um louise and tim and uh perhaps louise
you'd like to go first and just
introduce yourself and uh
what you've been commissioned to do okay
hi can you hear me okay everybody yep
i've
successfully unmuted myself um hi i'm
louise ashby
and um for those of you who don't know
me i've
spent a 20-year career
working in ad agencies and design
studios and brand consultancies
and i've looked after during that time
clients who have been anything from
startups to
smes to big corporates and public sector
organizations and charities
so i've kind of gathered quite an
insight to
how these organizations operate and the
various
outlooks for as far as sort of
marketing and communications goes
and i now work for myself as an
independent brand and marketing
consultant
um and i would say the heart of my
advice really is the premise that every
single action that you take within your
organization kind of contributes towards
your brand um
from how you train your people to how
you present your products and services
to
how you speak to your customers and um
of course that includes your online
presence and um
how you interact through all the social
media platforms that are available
um and
i've been commissioned to provide a kind
of package of support to local
businesses
during this tricky time um
in terms of social media and online
presence um
as we all know every business operates
with its own set of circumstances and
its own
set of challenges so i think that we've
kind of come to the agreement that
the best way to approach this is to be
entirely flexible
and to set up a kind of few sessions
with the businesses individually to work
out what their actual requirements are
initially um and kind of set up brand
brief interviews for them and once we
set a
set up a task list if you like of what
they
need and get to the bottom of what their
businesses are about
then i would go away do a bit of desk
research
[Music]
and that would be the second phase
come up with a kind of report looking at
competitors seeing what they're doing
seeing what the market trends are going
back to report that
um and then providing a session where
any specific training can be delivered
if you like so it's very much
not a one size fits all it depends on
what the individual businesses
challenges are
and what support they need so i'm pretty
flexible on
what i can offer for them
does that give you a round
idea yes yeah thank you louise so i
think i think just um
summarizing some of that so essentially
we'll be taking uh
applications to reform from any local
business
although i should point out that keep it
local
is focused around high street
facing customer facing businesses but
depending on the level of demand we see
any business can apply through an
application form which i'm about to post
into the
the link and depending on what they see
is their particular level of need
either louise with her skills and
expertise in digital marketing
or tim who will come to introduce
himself in the moment
um can be uh handed to that company
to give them a package of support
focused around what their needs are and
for us this was really important this
sort of needs based
support so it isn't what you click on
for a link
with with google or with facebook or
or anything like that this is tailored
to what you need where you see your
aspirations as a business in terms of
digital marketing
um and then louise will assist you in
identifying what those gaps and
opportunities
um are in terms of in terms of getting
there getting you there on that journey
so uh tim uh would you like to introduce
yourself in the same way
yeah thanks jack you'll have to forgive
me i've got a stinking cold
unfortunately
um thank you very much yeah i'm tim i'm
the it manager of
internet assist we are a modern-based it
services
company um we've i've actually been
working for internet assist now for
or over 18 years and we've been based in
in moulton for
for that time through a lot of
uh discussions and meetings over the the
many years now with
with the modern business uh board and
and various other things we've we've
seen in the last year that a lot of
businesses
um unfortunately have had to just shut
where
their online presence wasn't already in
place
um coming up to this uh obviously uh
pandemic
time um what we're hoping to be able to
help people now
is to a bit much like what louise has
said actually in the in the flexibility
in that
there'll be some people who won't have
any websites there'll be some people who
will have
a basic website or there'll be some
people that already have a
an e-commerce platform and are already
potentially selling their products
online
what we'd like to be able to do and
offer is a an overview and a report on
where that company currently is and
take into account where the company
feels they are trying to get to
and we can then help and advise um
to you know try and get them towards
being able to make
more of a um
to make more of a thing about what
they're trying to do online now
at the moment um you know i'm aware of
some of the the companies
um in mold and they're doing a lot on on
social media but
there's a big quite a wide scape of
people who
aren't even on social media who
potentially aren't being utilized to
sell products to
so um in a basic format we will look at
where the company is
right now and then try and make some
advice on where they can go and
what they can do and if anything it'll
also just give that company if they've
already got a website and they've
already got some sort of level of
uh position on
google and other search engines it'll
give them an idea of where they are now
as a snapshot and it might be that
actually
they better look at it and go we're
making good headway of of when we
started or
actually we're not getting far enough um
along in what we're hoping to achieve
so um yeah that's it in a nutshell we're
going to be flexible around what the
person has because we don't know what
the the company may or may not have
um in place at the moment so hopefully
we can
uh even if it's a small amount of advice
or a small amount of training or even if
it's
you know not necessarily about their
their their website as
you know we can help it service help to
help their business move along even if
it's just uh
to try and even bring in some i.t within
the business itself um
that's what we're hoping to help with
yeah thank you tim
um a question in the chat there from
amanda uh
no because you're on the key that that's
fine um
i think with both keys in both molden
and burnham
i think we will always understand them
as part of the
overall high street offer and in terms
of facing though it's just about
primarily it's about customer facing um
to be able to
give businesses who might normally uh
only reach their customer
across a counter that supports to
uh to enrich their offer uh through the
digital thing so i think
uh i think your uh application would be
uh looked upon
um perfectly fine um
yeah i think i think it's a really
interesting way i i'm quite pleased with
the way we've scoped this and
put this together because i think for a
lot of businesses you've probably seen
there is an enormous amount of
online webinars and training sessions
and things like that that are available
mainly to an open group or a class of
500 at a time or something like that
this is really about you
this is really about you and your
business and the time has been
commissioned with
uh louise and with tim and so
the time that they can give you um has a
rough limit to it you know a few hours
but they should be able to point you in
the right direction uh show you what you
um might need um and i think they're
i'm really hopeful that be helpful to
you so the form
i've posted there um in in the group
chat and of course we'll uh share this
uh more widely now we wanted this to be
the kickoff to the applications but it
doesn't preclude anyone who couldn't
join us today
um so that that form will be there
um there's a few questions in there that
we'll use to prioritize in case we are
heavily over subscribed
in the number of sessions we've
commissioned roughly it's about 20
businesses each
um but if we are heavily oversubscribed
we may
we may be forced to prioritize but to be
honest i would much rather
uh show that we're over subscribed and
find find some more money from somewhere
else which will be the other use for
that
uh data set the intention there is that
um ashley and i will review those um and
pass the contact details directly onto
tim and louise who will take take your
business forward on there
um and then all we ask willie in return
is that louise and tim will be providing
us a report and we'll ask you to
fill out a shortish form again
just to show how productive that's been
for you
and we're hoping it's a really useful
tool in two
areas that are critical to modern day
business
we recognize there's quite an overlap um
between what is
uh web and online and what is um digital
marketing
i think both uh tim louise and i'm
hoping you both say you've got the
expertise to probably support in an
all-round capacity um
but where where there is a challenge or
whether it's a
an overlap then we'll allocate
each business to one or you or the other
and perhaps
you too can talk if there's a an area
that you do have a gap in
thank you so yeah we will be sharing
this
um the great strength of the board is
that you all have your own
networks as well so when we push this
out through our social media
we'll share it with you in terms of the
links and so we can hope to reach as
many businesses as possible
um many of a few uh um you know
perhaps the old school who would also be
on the ground and
very welcome just to point this out to
people and apply i recognize that
applying for online training through an
online form is always a little bit um
ironic but uh i i think most people can
access forms nowadays
if there is if there is someone that
isn't then we might have to work out how
we reach them
by uh face-to-face anyway
good uh is there any questions on the
training element of keep it local
you're all gonna force me to talk
straight for two hours aren't you
um i'll just reiterate that this this
project's fairly small and it's it's
money we we have
grander ideas and we actually have a
larger sum of money to talk about a bit
later
this afternoon but it it would be
impossible
without um the work that we've done with
centreplace and with the business board
it's that it's the strength of
being able to show a need in the area
through our engagement with business i
just
felt like reiterating that because it is
what gives
this sort of partnership approach its
strength
and there will be further funds coming
jack should it would it would be
sensible for me to kind of introduce
salt marsh daily and talk about my
experiences certainly here
um with support i've received certainly
from tim um
which has been very strong um
no problem charlie go ahead so one of
the initiatives that center place looked
at
um gosh um just under a year ago was the
idea of trying to find a way of
supporting
local food and drink producers we have a
very large number of local food
producers
and drink producers in the area
and most of them have been badly
impacted by the pandemic in as much that
as we know
they have a vast amount of sales through
the hospitality sector
and a significant exposure because they
don't
they're not big enough or large enough
as brands
to have a foothold in the retail
multiples who have obviously
enjoyed quite a prosperous time during
the pandemic
so we came up with the idea about
setting up salt marsh delhi
which was basically an online grocery
web platform
uh one-stop shop as much as we possibly
could make it
for all the products that are produced
in the area now
obviously as you can imagine the idea of
a one-stop shop just in
in the immediate moulton district was
always going to be quite a challenge
um and therefore what we've tried to do
is to widen the
the definition of local into the rest of
the essex and in some cases where we
certainly haven't got
um essex producers actually encourage
producers from suffolk
um to to come and support us and and
that's been
uh frankly a large support so so
much delhi now is an online grocery
platform
delivering to the doorstep right across
essex
finding customers right across essex as
we know many people come from outside
the malden district come down to malden
for their holidays or just the weekend
trip
and they're very interested in trying to
buy and secure products that come from
local producers down here and we have
at the moment nearly 40 producers and
getting closer and closer to about 400
product lines
so quite a wide range not a complete
one-stop shop and we've got a lot of
work to do
to increase that we hope to add a number
of products in the coming months
to a wide but it has been a very
interesting launch
and the the most important thing has
been obviously getting the website right
and
tim has done a fantastic job in building
us
uh an online grossly platform at a very
economic cost
which a lot of people would certainly
our customers tell us
is very customer-facing and very
efficient and effective
and that's been a significant support to
the business
we have done all sorts of things in
terms of
uh social media marketing as well as
traditional marketing
um and the one thing we are grateful
having
got the business case together is
recently secure
some funding to provide for a driver
certainly within the first year from
magnox
because mcnox saw it as a real bonus
to be trying to bring all the local
producers together onto one platform and
really drive sales
so it's been a great initiative a lot of
hard work's gone into it
ashley's been a good support for us as
well in terms of her understanding about
social media
um and as i said it is it is the product
of
many businesses coming together to give
us the right level of support when i say
many businesses
it's it's not just tim but other
businesses there are producers behind us
who have been
uh very accommodating and really
encouraging us to
to try to take this forward we've been
trading for three months we're up to way
over 200 customers and
and the list keeps growing our big
challenge
in this case is getting our awareness
going so
i am taking probably a little bit extra
time just to enforce the awareness with
all of you because it's all about word
of mouth at the end of the day
so and that's been our success but that
i think is a really true product of what
coming to you know business is coming
together really
thanks charlie i think it's worth
pointing out that um
certainly from sense of place and from
uh magnox who are the funder of both
both uh pathfinder of both initiatives
um they see them as linked as our
efforts to try and support uh local
produce and business
um thinking on to the um
uh second bit of uh keep it local so
this is a bit
that we scoped up as if it as if we were
going to
run a sort of um pre-christmas campaign
and obviously fairly glad that we didn't
launch that
um at the time because that wouldn't
have been a very productive time to
welcome back and celebrate independent
shops on the high street
um but we have another part of the
funding that we've got
and that's going to go towards
commissioning a
marketing campaign so normally the
council run its own campaigns out of its
own
uh channels but um on this occasion um
we're going to be commissioning it
through someone else we haven't yet gone
to tender
yet so we'll be sharing that with um
local media
companies who may want to be able to um
support us in the campaign um and
and be paid to do so um
so that will be a large mass media
campaign essentially celebrating all
that the district has to offer
and celebrating and supporting the
the great value there is in shopping
local and keeping their business local
using local retailers to do their
business
working businesses working together
locally as well
and i think we've seen strands of this
in
in government messaging and there's a
number of ones that are
around um at a celeb level and at a
county level
trying to support this uh message of
uh keeping things local not just to
reduce transmission and reduce people
traveling
but also the great value that it brings
to communities to have
more sustainable businesses and more
money spent locally
and while i wouldn't want to necessarily
pull money away from tesco because they
are a
good big employer around the area i've
no no problem taking money out of
amazon's pockets
um and i think that's the that's the
real target that we've got here that we
need to
encourage people to to value what we've
got on our high streets and with our
independent businesses
and understand that spend with them
means a lot um
and means not only their own job and
income and security
but means that we continue to have um
the high street
thing high street businesses and high
street community
that we're all so fond of so i had hoped
for this time we would
have been out to tender but we had to
reshape it one because of christmas two
because of lockdown three
and then uh three because of uh click it
local
because we're going to obviously work
and synergize with the
campaign and the efforts they're going
to make in promotion
but essentially we have some campaign
assets worked up
and we're going to work with uh with
the organization that uh that we that we
choose through our tender process
to try and push this message with uh
local residents
uh to try and encourage people to return
to their high streets feel safe about
doing so and continue to spend their
money locally where it can have the
biggest impact
um and have the greatest outcomes for
them
um i can't remember the figure off the
top of my head maybe
charlie will remember it but what's the
thing if you spend the pound locally
30 pence of it stays local if you spend
it internationally if penny goes
only a penny stays locally um
there's great economic value in uh local
spend
um are you gonna uh tell me what it is
charlie
i i saw my head i can't remember there's
all sorts of different statistics
of which if you apply what's called the
multiplier effect which is the economic
idea that if you employ someone they go
and buy
food products and services themselves
and therefore that's a multiple effect
so
often people think that it's three to
four times uh
in terms of net monies that are kept in
the area
um the statistic i always like is that
if you actually go
um and spend a hundred pounds
um i always use the word down at tesco
and
and tip and jack's absolutely right we
don't really want to
harangue the local large employer but if
you go and spend 100 pounds and
load local multiple large multiple
you're more likely to see 30 pounds more
go
outside the area than if you would do if
you were shopping
at a local independent store um so
it's a significant amount and it's all
about that
that that dynamic certainly yeah
so we're commissioning that we're going
to ensure that that
that promotion that campaign aligns well
with
click it local and the efforts of local
businesses as well
and also um we're hoping to
are we hoping it will align well with
what's envisaged with fiberfest
um and allison do you want to say
anything on that at this time
i know i've just caught you unaware
haven't i about fiberfist
yes yep um so fibrefest i don't even
know when we had it last year
before lockdown lou can you remember
august maybe
i can't remember but um yeah we did
fiberfest last year which essentially
is um a national campaign run by a
company called totally locally
and totally locally um promote shopping
within your high street and it comes
back to
charlie and jack just said about
spending five pounds in your local high
street
and the impact that can have um which is
you know a greater impact than they have
had you got and spent it one of the
bigger
bigger suppliers so um yeah fiverr fest
uh we want to make it bigger and better
this year um last year
mike um bloomfield and myself mike was
think
uh creative at the time and we ran it
but actually we need more help this year
so if anybody in mulder wants to jump on
the bandwagon
and help me out then feel free to get in
touch
and it would be good to run it in
burnham as well so if anybody from the
burnham business board wants to speak to
me about how
we got that up and running then i'd be
happy to have a chat
so yeah that's gonna be on the 12th to
the 26th of june this year
yeah so we envisaged that the spend and
the keep it local
uh campaign will uh run still be running
at that point run alongside that
so one of the things we're sort of
talking about now is the sort of hero
products or
hero services that we're going to be
promoting so obviously focused initially
around
the high streets and the independent
businesses
but then of course we've got click it
local we've got salt marsh delhi we've
got fiverr fest
there's a number of really big stories
um that we want to use
uh the click the keep it local uh
campaign and keep it local money
um to really celebrate so um
i think sometimes it's useful to have
those real statement pieces within any
sort of
marketing the things that we're trying
to talk about rather than just saying
don't you remember it was lovely in 2019
please come back um saying about that
we're coming back bigger and better and
stronger
please support us we're also talking
about
uh running it so that it coincides with
the reopening of steps two three and
four
in the road map so that will be really
exciting
as we see uh very shortly uh pubs and
non-essential retail opening
and then uh indoor hospitality and then
finally the
release of restrictions assuming we
stick to timetable
so we'll use uh that campaign to um
punctuate each one of those
um activities and we're hoping to
bring forward some free parking in
malden
uh to support the activities there um so
that we can have a
nice safe ways to bring people back to
the high street
and then a few other ideas we've talked
about about perhaps uh
some temporary closures to the high
streets to try and create more space
in what is uh uh both of them have
challenges but molten is particularly
tight uh for space
great is there any questions on uh the
keep it local campaign
lovely thank you okay well we're hoping
to be joined by
um the clicket local team um fairly
shortly and so i'm gonna
slightly rejig the agenda or at least
the version i'm looking at
um because we've got uh another uh
potentially quite large
uh story to share um so we'll go on to
this and then
you'll forgive me if i have to switch
over when um the team from ticket local
are able to join us
hopefully in about 15 minutes
so we've been uh we've been notified by
um
which i call it mhclg which ministry of
housing communities and local
governments
um that out of the welcome back fund the
uh organization that businesses or
individuals may have seen
has been announced um although we
haven't been uh
prioritized as uh i think only tendering
was prioritized out of the um
the whole the larger pot but we have
been
notified that we should be getting
around 122
000 pounds um from the welcome back fund
and the intention of that is to among
other things is to boost tourism
improve green spaces provide more
outdoor seating areas markets
food stalls pop-ups and the list goes on
a little bit
i think they just sort of threw it out
there
but the idea is to give people more
space
and safer options to reunite with family
and friends
and for us we see this very much around
our high streets and our parks
and perhaps the smaller high streets uh
community spaces in um
in places like southminster and
tollesbury and things
so we will be talking with um parish
councillors this only came to us
late last week um and we thought we'd
missed out entirely but
i think we're we're pleased that mhclg
have recognized that
there are smaller and particularly
coastal uh towns
that face particular challenges and also
have great opportunities to
kick-start the economy particularly this
year with the amount of domestic tourism
we can expect to
see see in the area
so the intention there is to boost the
look and feel of high streets investing
in street parking or parks or green
spaces and seating areas
we can run publicity campaigns and
hold events like street markets and food
festivals
supporting local business and also
slightly more dull things of
more signage and floor markings and
floor stickers which i'm sure
everyone loves the floor stickers um
but it is focused around high streets
and space
for people so one of the things that
we will do is uh review the plans that
have been created by all the
plans that are under the sense of place
plan but also it gives us an opportunity
here
to for me to say again you know get get
your thinking caps on
um and if there are proposals uh that
you've always wanted to do
uh this will should not be all the money
uh that there is 122 000 does sound like
a lot
but you'd be surprised how quickly it
goes if it's spread between the
parishes
but if there is ideas and campaigns
that businesses want to see happen there
are
there could be funding available so i uh
you know we have a few minutes before
click it local join us
is there anything that people have had
as burning idea about
or what do businesses need out there at
the moment what's what is the crying
need
to be able to support recovery
can i just ask the question of
clarification jack because it obviously
is good news
um is the money going to be related as
you say to the
almost shall i say the visitor
experience
um obviously we want to encourage people
to come back
uh to the high street but are we looking
at initiatives that and then
inevitably lead people to visit burnham
and visit malden as a place
that they may go and enjoy and share you
know
and end up spending more time on the
high street i'm just thinking about the
the linkage say with prom park and the
high street and an initiative that
kind of bring the two together what what
we want to do is to see
the two come together more and there'll
be more linkage and people to stay
basically
longer um when when they come
would you say it was more related to
that or were we specifically looking at
projects that are
high street related i think i think the
reality is the funding um has come to us
quite flexibly and
and quickly um so you can imagine
essentially every
every district and town particularly
coastal area
has had the same letter with the same
guidance so we envisage there will be
more guidance to follow but
some areas don't have that
wonderful ability to link the park and
and the high street
um some areas do um so
there is still a slight question on
exactly what
mhclg expect us to do with this money
and what is within our discretion and
what isn't
but for us no that's very much aligned
with our thinking
it supports what's identified in the um
mold and central area master plan for
instance
and thinking that goes behind that so
yeah that
that is one of the areas that we see as
um
as a a suitable use of the money to try
and support that linkage between the
the leisure quarter and the high street
but obviously we your businesses will be
familiar with this
the government's announced these things
um in the press conference and then take
sometimes days sometimes weeks to
actually tell us how it's all going to
work
um but we we have been told what this is
going to focus on but it
it's a it's a page and a half letter
um and it does it does support
it does seem to be supportive of uh
tourism
of welcoming people back but i think
it's
um i think it's wide enough that we
could come up with good ideas and
and they would fit and i should point
out it's not a grant
uh sorry not uh uh we've been it's been
given to us
uh or will be being given to us so we
don't have to
apply for it which has been the case
throughout a lot of this that
these schemes come out and we have to
very hastily pull together a
a proposal in a fully costed business
case which is
a lot of effort sometimes um louise i
think you were first with your hand up
thank you i'm off from you yes i am um i
was just going to ask about the restart
grants
because i know that question keeps
popping up on on our business group
because we haven't heard anything yet
and i know a lot of people would
probably
need that money to invest in stock in
order to restart rather than
you know get it later on yeah let me
just check if i can find the latest on
that
um last time i checked we was
over a week ago um
let me come back to that um i'll get you
an answer just a moment
okay um michael um
yeah hi um is any is there any news on
the small grants so the um parking
payback can be launched
yeah in fact the meeting i was going to
have with um
with regards to that has clashed with
today um
so i don't have the news now um but yeah
i'm aware that's
one that you want to fund through this
but
we did secure it earlier before
christmas um
but i need to check it's still there so
yeah apologies on that one
kind of important to launch that at the
same time as kind of reopening the high
streets everything because i think it's
a
another thing that would incentivize
people to come to morden
and help on like a loyalty card and and
towards their parking play
yeah no that's fine um it's simply been
a case of
everything else that's been on um to get
a clear answer on that one
um i'll come back to you in uh
separately on that michael
uh louise on restart grant
um no it is still that there we haven't
opened it
um i was just looking at our web page um
but i'll see if i can find it
chase up with the team um and see if
they've got uh
an update on where they are with that
yeah it'd be really useful if we could
take that information back
because i know obviously everyone's
trying to get ready to open and we've
got less than a week now until we're
hopefully opening
yeah i was just going to check the
gardens because i can't remember if that
was
that can be paid now can't it
yeah it was from the first of april i
believe yeah
yeah i mean i think i've apologized this
um a couple of times the government
tends to tell us these things exist
um but the they they tell us at the same
time they tell you
um and as you can imagine it's quite a
convincing the council to simply
pay out 6 000 pounds to someone or 200
someone's
is not something that uh happens
overnight but yes you're right it's open
from the first of april i'll try and
i'll see if we've got an update for you
this week
is is it a separation process do you
know jack or is it just because we're
all
on the system already that's what they
were looking at
yeah so i don't know that's the answer
to that um
when when last i was able to talk to the
team it was last week and the guidance
has only just been released
so i i don't know what the what the
application process is going to be
or whether it will be simply a
roll on like the local restrictions
grants have been
okay sorry
allison i'm just going to ask in terms
of the
welcome background that you've mentioned
what's the kind of time scale on that
that
you expect one to receive the money and
then
for it to be spent by so i think
the issue we have at the moment is all
businesses are thinking about is
literally opening their doors
and they're not thinking about the
bigger picture of what can we get
involved in
and what events would help us it's a
really difficult question to answer
i think because everybody's minds are
just i think
on just getting excited to reopen um
yeah so in terms of the money it might
not be that
there's any ideas now that the high
streets will come up with but they could
come up
with them at a later later stage do you
think that money would still be there in
terms of
you know i don't know if we're looking
towards christmas or into the new year
or is it something we need to think
about now that's got kind of a
bit of a time limit on to spend it's
pretty much the exact question we went
to first of all and we all dug around in
all the guidance we could try and find
to see where the spend date was
um and we didn't we don't know we think
it's
we believe it's just going to be given
to us
um and uh there'll be a reporting
mechanism over
potentially the next year or year and a
half in terms of
uh what spend we are but the honest
answer is we don't know
um when we first had the meeting someone
chirped up and
suggested that they saw that it had to
be spent by
june this year and we're just like you
can't how can you do that it's not
possible
um and and that we had to talk to each
parish council
before we did before we did that and
you're like no
it won't be possible to get the reviews
of the business community
and every parish council so the answer
is you're right i
i it will heavily depend on what
um uh what the spend uh
timetable is um we know that some of
them
have been extremely short-lived in terms
of grants we've received for
community benefit in which where they've
got us a three-month
spend time table um and most projects
don't
don't get off the ground um within three
months
we believe this one will be longer
but the honest answer is all we have is
a page and a half letter
from mhclg so um
yeah my reason for raising it here uh
was really to
start trying to start that thought
process of um
what things could be done um but i
i really do sympathize i know that all
businesses will simply be
they will need to focus 100 of their
efforts um and their time and attention
on how they get their own uh businesses
up and running
and how they continue to do that safely
while
more restrictions and requirements and
everything is in place
okay thank you but yeah as just as a
final call if there is if there is this
burning idea
for the community or the high street or
something that's that's always wanted to
get off the ground it is an opportunity
to bring that and i was just bringing
that
through the the modern or the burnham
business board or indeed
if we do have anyone representing
outside of those areas
then through sense of place
good um is there any other questions
that we've got
on um welcome back not that obviously
most of that was just uh
more questions about it but any other
questions on uh welcome back grant at
this time
okay well i'm rather hoping we have uh
click it local
join us very shortly but i think
until they do if i can invite if there's
any
um other points that anyone else felt
they wanted to raise
charlie yeah i just really wanted to go
on from the comments
uh about this welcome funding that you
you've um
just mentioned i suppose
the point i would raise jack is that if
we're going to get
the most effective return for that
investment one of the best ways we can
do that
is to work with these business groups
the malden and the burnham
business group so that they can we can
coordinate the
the efforts in the right sort of way
rather than do a
kind of first come first serve basis
would you not agree
jack yeah all of the projects would be
identified with it would go through
um essentially some sort of form of
scoring matrix
to identify their their benefits and
beneficiaries and the outputs they would
they would do one of the things we spoke
about uh when we
we literally had a um a half hour
meeting
uh before we broke up for easter on this
um
was how can this fund be used to
leverage the best outputs
and obviously there's there's that sort
of thinking around match funding
um of whether this can be used
or perhaps even smaller amounts of it
can be used to leverage um
greater uh projects that are being um
thought about or being delivered
elsewhere
a kind of an example of that is what
michael was asking a moment ago in that
actually his group and his contacts have
done the bulk of the work around the
parking payback scheme
um the amount he wants and i keep being
a voice
avoided avoiding it is actually very
small to get the project off the ground
um but yeah that type of project is very
um
a very positive use of this type of fund
great well as if they knew we'd just oh
michael you've still got your hand
up but uh well interesting for zoo jack
and to
addison gray um as you know i
i arranged the christmas event every
year and hopefully now
if everything goes well with in june
um we will get the green light well i
will give the green light for the
christmas market to go ahead now one of
my biggest problems i have is
raising sponsorships and every year i
have a target of about ten thousand
pounds to raise and
i'm pretty close to that but i've been
doing some research and
other towns the actual shopkeepers make
a contribution towards the actual
christmas event
and why i've asked addison to kind of be
listening on this one as well as she's
with her
large business group uh or you know the
shopkeepers
it is quite normal because it is
hard work getting the sponsorship and
every year
town council say to me okay michael you
know what's the budget this year well
i've managed to negotiate on the
christmas lights and got it down from 15
000 to 13 000 pounds which we
paid from the town council's money um i
just want to announce them what your
thoughts are which is normal in other
towns
as it is an event for the whole town and
it generates revenue for all the
businesses
whether you think within your people
they would make a contribution
i know it's bad timing because i'm not
even open at the moment so
let's say hypothetically we discuss this
in june or july when everyone's
chills are rattling again yeah i don't
think
i mean i've contributed before and i
i don't see why people wouldn't want to
contribute um
providing they decide to stay open on
the on the evening
um but i think it's about not one size
fits all
so whether or not you could look at
you know a payment i don't know based on
size of property
i don't know how you would do it but it
would seem it wouldn't be realistic for
instance for mrs salisbury's to pay the
same
a shop like myself you know so i think
if you can come up with some kind of
structure
maybe even based on on business rates i
don't know
or maybe it probably needs to go even
lower than that because
a lot of big companies still fall into
the
great relief um yeah i can't see i can't
see
allison location has a part in that as
well
and your slap bang at the top of the
middle of the high street you're going
to get
loads of people and if you're off to the
side you're not necessarily going to get
familiar yeah
that might be a factor too we'll have
the issue that last year and i think the
year before there was quite a few
complaints
um from a number of businesses where
food stores were put outside
their tea rooms so i think they'd have
to have some kind of
you know you'll pay this fee but it
gives you this is what we guarantee will
not happen this time and you know
um because nobody's going to want to pay
a fee and then find that they've
you know a tea room's got a coffee stand
outside it so
yeah i think if it can be seen to work
for them i don't see that people
would object um but i think it's just
about this year keeping the fee
low i mean basically any donation really
helps but perhaps
once you know once we get a green light
in june then perhaps
we can we can discuss this with your
group
see anything to support the town because
uh it is hard work and
uh and they the town do rely on it
for sponsorship so okay well as we've
got people waiting in line now we'll
we'll come back and practice once we'll
get the green light on this and i'll
come back
thank you michael thank you alison and
you might want to look at the notes
amanda put
um as a quite perhaps a clever way to
put it
um to suggest that a percentage of the
uh
takings during that period during that
evening
could be identified for the following
year
um might be a novel waiter um to do that
and obviously it allows
the business to be um
to have a in time discussion with you
about what sort of percentages
is reasonable over that because some
businesses have uh
a very high level of cost involved in
staying open
whereas some would want to do it to be
part of the community event that it is
yeah i think that's a difficult one
because you're asking businesses to
share what their takings are and i don't
think you'll find many businesses want
to do that
i'll leave it at that that's a tricky
one but um yeah
that we could definitely do something so
yeah
good well uh timing worked out quite
well because we we've come to the end of
the things that i wanted to talk about
and i could do with a break from talking
so
uh if i may introduce uh and steve who
have
joined us now from uh click it local um
are you there and they will talk to us
guys
we are yeah can you hear us we can hear
you yes
and we can now see you steven hello
steve thanks for your uh
journey and good time into london
luckily i didn't hit lots of traffic so
i arrived with 15 minutes to spare so
um absolutely fine great stuff steve if
i just briefly introduce you to the
group you're talking to now so
uh we've met before uh i'm jack allen
from the council and there's also my
colleague ashley with us
um with us here is a collection of
members who
make up uh part of the molden
um business board and the burnham
business borders our two main
dwellings in the district um and we also
put this invite out publicly so we've
got a
a few others um who have uh kindly
agreed to
to join us here um or uh with you as the
headliner steve so um
here we go no pressure
cool so over over to you steve um i i
haven't really done an introduction um
perhaps at the end i can i'll just
tell people how click it local has come
about with uh with the council
um but i think these are your potential
customers
each of them represents um a bit of a
network in their own right
um so we'll assist you in spreading your
spreading your news
alison your hands up is that for now or
is that from uh
and you're muted
that's right to you then steve okay cool
no worries well
i'll do some quick introductions and
then um i've got a deck that i mean i'll
share i'm not sure how long i've got but
i'll share a deck with with you and give
you a quick rundown of kind of what
clicker local is how it works etcetera
um but there's uh so you've got myself
um steve so i'm i'm one of the two
founders of click it local
and there's also emma on the line who
works
in conjunction with the councils that
we're working with across essex
um and then also kavali who's on the
call
who basically is um dealing with uh the
store relations
new business and support um within
within your area basically um so you've
got three of us on the call
um i will if that's okay i'll run i'll
run through
a kind of a ten minute presentation just
for anyone who doesn't know
what clicker local is and and how it
works um i'll kind of run you through
that
and then i'm sure there'll be some time
for some questions
um as well um so let me just
uh share my screen
a second
[Music]
sorry i'm just trying to find the share
screen
[Music]
okay here we go perfect
uh can everyone see that okay
yes yeah great let me just
get it
screen perfect there we go
um so yes so click a local um
marketplace for independent shops so
um our we launched in cambridge um 11
months ago now
um really with the sole intention of
looking at
you know how do we um empower
independent businesses
on you know local high streets to
compete with the likes of um you know
amazon
supermarkets and other large online
retailers um
so for us there were two things that we
wanted to to kind of create in in doing
that i think the reasons that um
individuals maybe shop on those
platforms are one
you have a massive choice of products on
one place so
you know on on one website um or
certainly you know in any other store so
massive choice um and then
also um same day next day delivery
or or delivery to your door within a
week with supermarkets so
there's two aspects really massive
choice and convenient
delivery to your door of all of those
items so for us it was about creating
those two elements and bringing those
two elements
um in a very similar way to shoppers but
driven by independent businesses um so
you know
the idea really is by pulling all
independent businesses together
you know within a you know 20 30 mile
radius
basically means that we are able to give
shoppers a really large choice of
products right through you know from
food to fashion to plants a real mixture
of products um yeah that kind of comes
in with our our aim as a business is
get you know 70 of uk independent shops
online delivered same day
on the same website so it becomes as it
grows
um a real uh contender for some of those
um you know big online retailers and
uh you know really uh yeah ultimately
stronger together as independent
businesses
um so here so we obviously combine the
convenience of online shopping
and same-day delivery with the economic
and environmental benefits of shopping
local
so obviously lower emissions in terms of
delivery so obviously we're trying to
keep our deliveries as local as possible
where we can in the city centers we're
using bikes um and we're
we're starting to look at how we start
to integrate electric vehicles in more
more rural areas um generally i think
there's an advantage with working with
independent businesses generally there's
less packaging so obviously we're
pushing to
also assist with that where we can and
then obviously local stronger economy
you know
we want shoppers to spend their money
locally
to uh retain and keep keep the economy
as as strong as possible
um so like i said making shopping local
easier faster more convenient and more
socially responsible than likes of
amazon
um so just i'll run through how it works
really for you know shoppers
um shops um and then how how delivery
works so
um from a shopper's point of view um
you're able to
visit click it local.credit uk you will
um
you know pop in your postcode or your
location
and essentially what it will do is bring
up all the stores that are available
in your area now it will start
specifically
local to you so it will be the most
local stores to you will come up first
um followed by the surrounding um areas
um further down um you're able to shop
in kind of three different ways
i mean it's really to replicate what
you know consumer behavior is used to
with some of those larger online
platforms so
you can shop by shop so when you go
you'll have a list of all the shops
you can go in and you can add add the
various products um
to to your basket you can shop by
category so a bit like you would maybe
do on a supermarket you know
you could go to food and drink we could
go to fashion and shop by category add
everything to the basket
or you can just search like maybe you
might do on amazon you search for the
product and then again you can add it to
the basket
um as a shopper you you add everything
from multiple retailers you pay in one
go
and then you get one consolidated same
day or next day delivery depending on
what time you order
and then you know how it works for shops
so
shops can set up their stores um really
easily
um you know through through our
dashboard you're able to just click a
link
at the bottom of the website and also um
obviously kavali in in your case will be
there
um to support wherever needed um
now there's there's a seven and a half
percent fee apart from
uh you know where we're launching in
essex actually the council is
subsidizing that fee so for the first
six months it's it's a zero percent fee
so there is no fee
um for stores and then
um from a delivery point of view so
again
as i mentioned like one of the key
elements is we set up an infrastructure
when we
go into an area so that we're able to
one with our website offer a large
choice with all the retailers
but secondly to that offer a
consolidated delivery service so
um you know once someone's placed their
order essentially what we do if they've
ordered from
five different shops um we will
essentially collect all of those items
and consolidate it and deliver it uh to
their door
and the the delivery cost is basically
between um three pounds to six pounds
depending on how many retailers
shoppers order from but it won't go any
higher than six so you can order from 10
retailers and it will still cost you six
pounds
um this is a little bit just
just just on how that consolidation
process
actually actually works
so for any customers that order before 1
pm
can get same day delivery if it's after
one then it will be next day delivery
but what happens at one o'clock our
couriers then basically go to all of the
stores in the areas
they collect between 1 and 2 p.m
they then consolidate they bring those
back to basically our local
consolidation hub
and in in regards to essex we're having
one consolidation hub in chelmsford and
another in colchester so basically
everything goes to the consolidation hub
that gets consolidated there and then it
gets delivered between three and seven
pm
um just kind of top-line key features
but for us obviously
thousands of products large range of
stores a multi-category marketplace say
you know just a choice across multiple
categories multi-store consolidation
um same day local delivery and
subscriptions is another thing that we
offer so
um customers are you know able to set up
their own subscriptions to
any store on any sort of regularity if
the store
um allows it so you you know you have a
real choice
um of items that you can subscribe to um
in terms of growth you know it's grown
a lot over the last kind of 11 months as
we've grown
um and then number of stores so we're
actually about
um 1250 stores now um 250 of which
are um across essex um
so far in the in the areas that we're in
um
and uh in terms of choice of products so
it's a real real wide variety again
we're actually up to about kind of
twenty twenty thousand dish products
um of choice at the moment um
so yeah massive that's the choice of
products
um and then just i'll obviously share
this deck with you after so you can have
a read um
after um but here's an example of some
of the kinds of retailers that we work
with um so um this is a lady called
small and green um she she's got
business yeah small and green they're
based in cambridge
um she's a market trader um she works
from home the rest of the time
um and she sells plants she's a
relatively new business
um she launched about two months before
kovid and
so the platforms worked really well for
her so she's she's kind of
got you know um over 30k of revenue so
far which is which is great
um when compared to kind of more you
know um
conventional high street shop
long-standing shop
in cambridge um you know been there for
a long period of time with a very loyal
customer base and again it's worked
really well for them
as you know an additional means of
revenue because i think that's the key
is that um obviously we want
your local customers and people within a
local area to be able to obviously shop
from
from the shop but it's also about
opening you up wider a field to offer
same-day delivery for a much wider area
which basically means there's a whole
load more customers that maybe wouldn't
usually shop from you as a retailer but
actually
now can shop me really easy and get fast
delivery so i think that's
it's all about increasing your revenues
and adding additional revenue
on top of um your your base level of
kind of local customer as well
um yeah we're stronger together
something that's really important when
we're launching in any areas
is the kind of the social media um that
we do
in conjunction with the stores the
closer we work with the stores the more
the stores are on board
and we're promoting alongside um the
better it works for
for the stores so you know it's it's a
real key thing that you know we're
you know generating and creating offers
to help kind of you know push our
customers accordingly
we're doing a whole load of paid
advertising in the background with kind
of instagram
and and facebook in those areas for the
specific stores
and then kind of you know social media
campaigns um
that we work with in conjunction with
each store creating content
um so yeah i'm gonna stop there if
that's okay
so i'm gonna
stop sharing
work my back now i'm back
yep i'm back thank you so sorry if that
was too quick hopefully i try to
i'm quite used to going through it now
so i hope it wasn't too quick and
everything made sense
thank you steve well i've just put the
latest news dot
article um into the chat for anyone who
wants to pick that up
um and see how it's working i mean for
us
this is uh quite an exciting uh
opportunity and partnership
this is a project we're working with the
north essex economic board
which is a partnership between ourselves
chelmsford
tendering braintree colchester i think
that's it
so we're going to be bringing click it
local to all of those areas i think
i think steve's probably been on the
call with um half of those
areas over the last uh few days no doubt
probably a couple this morning
uh am i writing saying chelmsford just
launched
yes exactly so chelmsford launched so
actually huttlesford we launched um
three christmas
um but um then absolutely so chelmsford
uh last week and then we've got um
colchester and braintree
this week you guys on the 20th and then
um tendering on 27th of april so most of
essex um you know over the next few
weeks basically
and we really want to see this as an
additional string to
our high street retailers bo this is
really about the
um the way we're going to push this is
is to those
uh independent businesses um focused on
the high street
um excitingly we uh orders through click
it local for us consolidate uh
colchester unless that's changed in the
last few days um
and that means that anyone from um the
braintree colchester or tendering
districts which
equates to uh 230 000 households
um can order uh next day or same day um
through click it local freud on the
independent stores of malden and
obviously and
of course across the district um and
obviously we
we don't have quite as big a business
base as some of our bigger cousins in
culture store and braintree and
chelmsford
but we do do well with our local
independent businesses and our
entrepreneurs so we're really hoping
this is a good way to support them
if you're willing steve i'll hand over
to some questions uh yeah absolutely
yeah fire away great stuff allison
hi steve hi dean good thanks
um i signed up um i think last week just
putting my initial details of my
my business um am i right insane it
looks like
as a shop we have to upload our products
onto your website
is that right you do yeah absolutely so
um
you do upload your products now you can
add you know 10 products or
100 products um but it obviously um yes
takes every time but yeah absolutely you
upload your your products um
we haven't got a way yet to kind of
integrate because there's so many
different retail systems that everybody
is is using
um it's a little bit of a challenge for
us to kind of link in with those yet the
plan will be to do so
but absolutely right you'll upload your
products that you've got at the moment
and you can choose whether you just want
to have the ability to
set your items you know a quantity if
you like you can obviously set
quantities for your items
or you can choose just to have kind of
an in or out of stock slide of art
different things work for different
businesses
so if we chose for instance to upload
six of an item
does your does the click it local
website enable that to kind of count
down
and do it you just need to let us know
if you want an inventory because
basically half of our retailers do and
half don't so we basically
it's set to not have it but if you want
to have it just let us know we can just
turn it on for you basically
and then you can set a a number um
sometimes the challenges for retailers
is
you might be selling in in multiple
areas so you might be selling
online through your shop so setting a
quantity can sometimes be challenging
because it might be misleading if you go
out of stock somewhere else and that's
sometimes the balance
and i had a question and from somebody
that was quite
interested but couldn't attend today
they are a tea room and
now they currently offer nationwide
delivery on afternoon teas
but they like the idea of being part of
the click it local
however their their agreement they
already had with the public is that they
were delivered before 11 o'clock in the
morning
so i'm assuming that the times are kind
of quite set and they have to be
yeah so what because it's afternoon teas
they obviously want to deliver at 11 so
you've got it for the afternoon
basically
yeah it's a it's a tough one because
yeah you're absolutely right
it is quite a restricted time window and
that's because
we're kind of doing the consolidation
yeah so for us like the economies of
scale as deliveries grow
work because we do that process in the
day
um between those certain times yeah
obviously
people can get delivery in the evening
and it would be tomorrow but obviously
depending on what it is will depend
whether
that works or not um so the answer is
kind of no we can't guarantee a pre-11am
delivery on that note with with
businesses that do
have fresh produce they wanted to get on
board
you've got the cheese company so i'm
assuming you've got some sort of setup
that when it gets to your depot it's
refrigerated or
how does that work yeah so we basically
i mean we have so we have cooler boxes
we use
um when we need it obviously we've got
about a three hour window from the point
that they're collected to when they're
delivered
now a lot of the retailers we work with
even the ones that
um you know offer cool items so that the
cheese company do national next day
delivery for example
and various ones of the kind of the meat
and fish companies that we work with
also do deliveries and actually can do
so a lot have
packaging that allows it to at least
last for a period of
three to four hours so whilst we
obviously you know do our
best to have refrigerated items in
cooler boxes
we also request our retailers kind of
make sure they package it in a way that
it will last for that three to four hour
window as well
okay um last question from me is there
any
is there any limit on size or weight
or anything like that yeah so we
actually haven't had this problem yet
where it's come up a couple of times in
questions um we can't deliver sofas
i mean but that honestly we haven't
really had the problem with
uh furniture or really large items
so far um so you know i mean we deliver
quite big plants
i mean we delivered um you know compost
from
uh garden centers someone ordered like
six or seven bags so
there is you know we don't generally get
really large items on there
we can facilitate it to a point um but
but yeah there's no
we haven't put a set weight limit or
size limit because it's not been
yet is it the bike you pick up on the
bike that was in the pictures
uh depends on the area so we used bikes
in the city centers so like colchester
chelmsford cambridge
once we start to get maybe uh slightly
more rural or smaller market towns
then we'll often do it then with with a
vehicle at that point just because of
based on what we're doing and
just depends on the landscape basically
where we are
okay thank you that's all from me no
worries you alison
um anyone else for some questions yeah
am i harry
sorry go to mary please first yeah
hi um i hope i haven't been distracting
you in the background because i'm
actually packing
here i see you're busy but that's fine
yeah a really busy weekend thank god uh
right just about the delivery charges
can you kind of tell me a little bit
more about that you said mentioned
between
three and six rounds
that's fine so basically if it's one if
you went online and you just ordered
from
one retailer um it would basically be
three pounds
um if you're yeah
so when i as a customer i will i pay the
three quid for delivery
yes so the customers customers pay for
delivery exactly that yeah so customers
are paying for delivery um but but if i
order from one shop it will cost me
three pounds
it will cost one pound for each
additional retailer but it will cap
out at six so with it with the idea that
we want customers to order from as many
shops as possible and we don't want them
we don't want them to feel
like the delivery cost is going to get
too expensive so between three and six
is quite good but then you can order an
unlimited number of retailers
okay and so then after the first six
months and the fee
to us is seven and a half percent
exactly yeah exactly that yeah and the
delivery is by the customer
that's it that's correct right sorry can
i can i chip in there steve because i
think
i think i'm right and saying it's seven
and a half percent but there's also the
1.4 and the 20p
just yes there's a card transaction fee
that we that we get charged like you
would in a shop anyway basically so that
comes actually is there basically but
just make sure that that's on top of the
seven and a half percent
yeah so just for clarity it's seven and
a half percent which is
click locals fee yeah at 1.4 is the
transaction
fee and there's a 20p um stripe
fee exactly yeah and for the first six
months
right for the first six months it's just
that 1.4
plus 20p after the six months or the
time of which we're
um we're commissioning the service and
local move to a sustainable
uh position uh within the area and then
it's
uh seven and a half yeah
could that that's quite interesting
about that delivery charge because that
was one of the things i was a little bit
concerned by because we actually offer
free delivery within more and haybridge
we started at the beginning of the
pandemic last year
obviously let me be charged outside of
that that area
and i was a little bit concerned that
you know somebody
oh i'd like to pay the emporium or you
know or three quid
get something from the emporium well
actually they you know they can deliver
free
however the fact that as you say you can
click collect from more and more shops
and it's going to be three quid for one
uh or six
creed i think that kind of then makes
makes it
probably viable for us as well yes
that's right and a
wide area as well i think that's the
other thing because like i guess you you
can offer free delivery
in a very close proximity not to some
wide area every single day and that's
where the advantage is yeah
yeah that's really helpful thank you
thank you mary um
michael please yeah um first of all
before i'm gonna say what i'm going to
say i think it's a very brilliant
concept
however sounds like a politician yeah i
don't know
um don't you think you are a politician
michael yeah i am
reliant michael fellman so i am an mp i
suppose um
but we've been discussing through
more than business board etcetera sense
of place
about increasing the footfall into the
high streets basically
i think this is taking it away from the
high street because we have to remember
but we have
nearly 35 to 40 eating and drinking
places in the high street so we need to
encourage people
into the high street not only to go and
visit the shops
but to keep the refreshment side vibrant
and i can see this that it's actually
going to take away
the football of the town and also the
other question is
maybe to the shopkeepers is that after
the
six months it works out nearly that
you're going to pay
10 percent does that mean that the
shopkeepers will be increasing their
prices by 10
which would make them uncompetitive to
people like amazon and ebay
cool that's fine so i'll touch on your
your first one to start with so i mean
our our whole model
is about keeping the independent high
street there
and viable and people able to stay on
those high streets and continue to do
business
i think the thing to consider is that
the football
is exceptionally important to retain but
the pressure for high streets has been
there for the past 10 years from online
retail and whilst
increasing football is super important
there is also the reality that there is
going to continually be the pressure
from online
so actually empowering those
independents to offer it not going
well they shouldn't offer it but we
should just get more footfall
means that what's going to happen is all
of those customers that are shopping
online due to convenience
will shop online without those
independents so the whole point is
is drive additional revenue to those
businesses on those local high streets
from a wider area so it's actually if
they can still get their football and
their local business but actually
capture more of everybody's shopping
basket that happens online at the moment
with amazon's and
and you know supermarket then that's
what it does for them it gives them
additional revenue than what they would
get from their football and if they
don't have that
and that footfall or you know um online
ordering increases
then i think that's where there's a
balance with that so ours is all about
keeping them there
but supplying additional revenue
okay now what about the case of perhaps
one of the shop
people like addison or someone could say
then um
[Music]
that after six months it you keep within
the scheme
it's going to hype effectively cost you
another 10
are you willing to do you mean that you
have to increase your prices to cover
that 10 percent
or are you willing to lose 10 percent
off of your profit
to keep it within the scheme
can i just add one thing just but i know
someone else can answer it is
on additional revenue so i think that's
the important thing to highlight is that
there is a percentage for extra revenue
coming into the business it's not like
it's ten percent off of all the business
you're getting of people coming into
your shop at the moment
so it's ten percent on what you're
getting extra so i think that's
that's right you know and i've been
through this for running various
businesses but
um yeah turnover is it's great but
you've still got to make a profit you
can do a million a year and make 5 000.
you know
so it's important that i know that
with some of the schemes i've tried to
work even trying to give an additional
5 discount from some of the shopkeepers
has been difficult because
they have to hold on to their margins so
perhaps
perhaps one of the shopkeepers could
come in on that you don't mind jack
no i think that's fair i i do see um i
do see the point
um but yeah uh a lot of shopkeepers want
to come in on that
matter of yeah i'm happy to jump in on
that
um because i i just want to add one like
i said at the beginning actually that it
is a fantastic scheme and i love the
idea of it i think it's great
um i i think to broaden advertising
um you know your reach on advertising is
fantastic
so for me personally and i i suspect
this might be an issue for a few people
is yes your margins are quite tight so
um
initially it seems wonderful because
obviously the costs are low it's quite a
jump then to
to consider afterwards now my delivery
costs
are very similar to what you're um
offering
a same as mary we do free local delivery
actually up to within 10 miles of the
shop which is quite a broad radius
and then after that it it goes up in
stages you know the first sort of range
is five pounds
postage is usually less than five pounds
anyway um nationally so
it's not much different so for me i'm
looking at it as an advertising
um thing so if to to jump up with the
the cost yes i probably would have to
put my prices up on the click it local
site which would then wouldn't work with
all my my other website and the and the
prices i'm offering in shocks obviously
i've got to be consistent across the
board
um my biggest concern at the moment is
the fact that um
as alison asked you about uh loading
things onto the website you have to add
them on individually
i've got about between 1200 and 1500
lines of stock
and it took me a solid month working
almost full time
to get my website up and running in
november luckily we were in lockdowns
had all the time in the world to do it
so it was a fantastic opportunity
but going forwards ordinarily i wouldn't
have that resource within the day to do
that
and also i keep my stock levels quite
low because i have to i can't carry huge
amounts of everything
and so trying to manage that across
three sites my own website the shop and
the click it local website as well
would be almost impossible to manage i
think so they're my main concerns
i think steve you could probably address
a couple of them yeah i mean certainly
so
so stopwatch sorry my kids are in the
background they are being quiet but
we're enjoying it it's fine
all right at least it's not like i don't
know if you've seen the one like online
where they're doing a news feed and they
like
push their kid out but um yeah so kind
of just i like the pic is that a pickle
rick
yeah i don't know what it is to be
honest maybe it is
okay it's pickle rick it's very cool
there you go um so uh sorry i
said uh so uh yes stock so and and
uploading products so what we
whilst we don't have a bulk upload um on
the dashboard at the moment
um we are able to do it in the
background so like if you have 1200
products and you're able to do some sort
of
export from your um existing program
that you're using whether it's shopify
or something else
we can import that you just need to
supply it to us and we'll
import that obviously we want to get as
many products on as possible um
the stock levels though is definitely a
challenge because so many people use
different platforms
at some point we will you know integrate
with um
you know the shopifys of the world uh
magento
um so that they can track but i imagine
that you might also use a different
system in your store as well as what you
use
on your website at the moment i don't
know if they delay do they track each
other
at the moment or not no so so that
that's basically that's the real
challenge at the moment is so many
systems don't track each other
um we actually in the future would like
to get it to the point
that you know um we we can but there is
a limit we can't do it instantly we
can't
link to everyone so yeah that there's a
balance but we can upload all the
products for you
and can i add confidence um
so in terms of the delivery if somebody
because it covers colchester and
different areas outside of malden
can a customer order from five different
um different locations within that
okay so somebody could literally order a
dress from colchester
some soil from malden and it would all
go within that six quid
yeah okay and then my second question is
what happens if an order goes missing
who's responsible for the cost of that
i mean if it's if the order goes missing
and it's and it's obviously
you've handed it over and we've we we've
got it then then it's us and then we
obviously cover the cost of that
that item obviously there's a few
different reasons but you know if
something gets damaged in transit again
that's our responsibility um you know so
so those if it's in our hands and it's
our responsibility then we cover
we cover the cost of that you know
obviously if a customer breaks it
you know after it's been handed over
then that's that's them
or if there's i don't know with the
product then obviously
that kind of is the retailer side but um
and then and then it will be returned so
there's a few things when it comes to
returns
um obviously if it's our responsibility
we'll return it
and obviously cover the cost of that
item if the customer wants to return it
they get given the option to either drop
it off at the store
or drop it off our local consolidation
hub and then we'll get it back to you
which is a bit like amazon you drop it
off at wherever
the drop-off point is for you um or if
it's a manufacturing issue or i don't
know if it was the wrong product that
was sent out
then we will collect it or it can get
dropped off but then obviously
that's then on the store to organize
that bit or we can do it for them
um but yeah and what do you do with the
deliveries so
um in terms of i guess it's your own
staff doing the deliveries yeah
do you knock and leave on a doorstep or
do you
leave a note how does all of that work
yeah
um so basically all of our delivery
drivers so
when we we employ delivery drivers
locally so in this instance across the
essex district
they all kind of are on the outskirts we
employ they all kind of
drive to the consolidation hub which is
colchester
they collect on the way from the stores
they consolidate there and then
everything goes back out they're almost
like you know um
driving um home beyond that point um
and then they obviously just just just
kind of drop off um
as they go okay
sorry what was the other point your
question what's it what if somebody's
not home
so a bit like sorry amazon will drop it
on your doorstep whereas
yeah you know yeah yeah so we will do
the same
so you can leave a note when you order
so when you order you can leave like a
delivery load so if it's like i've got a
shed please leave it in the shed then
then we'll obviously get that message
and we'll do it accordingly um the
delivery drivers are allowed to leave it
with uh potentially with a neighbor or a
space that they
see fit if you're not available every
delivery driver has
um the contact details so they can call
the customer as well so
if they can't get hold of you they will
try calling the customer um if they can
leave it somewhere they'll take a photo
let us know our customer services and
then we'll obviously let the customer
know
if there's nowhere to leave it safely
and then they won't they'll obviously
bring it back
um and we'll we'll try and contact the
customer
and if not return it to the store but
that doesn't happen very often to be
honest
i assume steve because it's same day or
next day the customer
knows that they're going to be receiving
that order
um it's a lot more um obvious than
people who placed the order and said
sometime in the next three weeks
and you have to you wait around at home
all day
your delivery slot is is well known at
the time of ordering
and there's also quite a small window
isn't it um it is
and actually something we're we're
adding on as well in the background is
like a bit like you get it with dpd
where it might tell you what number slot
you are so there's
20 the driver's got 20 deliveries today
and your number
15 and it will let you know so we're
going to start adding that in so
there'll be kind of more
regular updates for customers on when
their delivery is coming
um for us that minimizes customer
services because
like the sometimes the most questions we
get are when is my order coming
what times are going to arrive even even
if there's a window so it
helps us basically okay jack
awesome yeah oh okay um
i've got a 3 15 appointment so i need to
shoot
steve thank you um i definitely think
it's
looking into this a little bit further
it's interesting i think
lou would agree as another high street
shop owner and mary
um so anything i need to catch up on can
i do that at a later date
and i think i think to summarize the
next step for people is there's the link
in our press release and we'll be shared
with the minutes of this meeting
um the next step guys is to to sign up
um
or find more information um but to sign
up if you're interested
um louise the point about the number of
products i was going to suggest
i i don't think you're going to want all
your products listed on
click it local but of course there will
be ones that work and ones that don't
things with very small margins that you
hold for different reasons for
convenience to the customer
that aren't going to necessarily work
through this model
but there will be ones that you know
you're going to be opened up to 10 times
the amount of households
if you do district-wide delivery at the
moment that's
around thirty thousand or around twenty
seven thousand
um it's going to be 230 000 households
um that will be able to order uh for
same day delivery
uh through this site and um yeah just
doing
uh do your top 10 top sellers i guess
guys and and see how it works that would
be my approach just before i go steve
because i need to shoot
um do you have any businesses that you
think would be willing to chat to us
about how it's worked for them and
yeah more more than happy to so yeah
i'll um
i'll try and select like a mixture of
businesses obviously
what people do it will obviously be a
mixture so yes
i'll pick a mixture of business
um yeah give give everyone an insight
absolutely fine
perfect thank you right i'm going to
shoot thank you so much thank you very
much
bye bye alison thank you very much
okay guys well um i think i think i hope
that's been really helpful i think
there's quite a number of things
um that um have come up there and uh
a good number of initiatives that we've
done
um uh steve romer is there any final
comment from you guys
um are you all happy with your your
slots and your pitch
absolutely you know for us if there's
any questions just um
getting contact we'll